ます
本日はこちらにあります通り買ってきまし
ているとニーズの把握というテーマでお
話しさせていただきたいと思いますどうぞ
よろしくお願い致します
はいまず簡単に自己紹介をさせてください
そこは彼を買っている国際公共政策だった
の4回生です
でのボランティアサークルのぷろんてぃあ
という団体に所属しておりまして
まあ論やは主に障害者福祉を専門医を使う
番系団体なんですけれども与えは10
ジョン役であったりとか
介護であったりとか献血さだったりとか
あんま様々な活動をやっていますでは他社
の中でましょう
芝と一発同2まあ主に命に関わってまいり
ました
まあパニック1年は変わってきた人間なと
いうふうに覚えていただければ嬉しく思い
ます
それはボランティアについてなんです
けれども
ボランティアのイメージ
どういう異常なと思ってさ
たとえバー
まあ社会党県であるというイメージがある
と思います
まあ企業社会光景活動なんかでもま
俗に言う cl があるんですよね小さな
花でもこういう海溝型のボランティアって
いうのは砲金クローズアップし高度され
たりしますよねそういう晩成社会党系の
イメージが合ってるする
まあ
例えばほかにも学生だったら中核によりな
んじゃないかって言い
ブーバー行為ますよ
以前
これはね例えば自己満ぶっていう言い回音
が出ているかもしれないんですけど
私自身の中古品友達にさびさにあった時に
マイナーにしても惹かれてはボランティア
やってるよって言った内部いきなり全車
物件のみたいと言われたりするんですよね
もちろん我々はまあ先にとかマジな話しし
ておきますけど以前ではれないような自己
満足って言われないような相手のために
なるような役に立てるようなそういうふう
に頑張って活動をしているんですけれども
またも偽善っていうものに関して
ボランティアんって言うこと聞いて
にょん
聞いてしまうと逆に不安なんじゃない
かっていうそういうふうに思ったんですね
というわけでまあこちら
偽善って言うでも一番最初に持ってきてお
話を進めていきたいとおもいますこの3つ
のテーマでお話しさせていただきます
はいまた事前の前
なんのこっちゃと思われた方も
いらっしゃるかもしれないんですよ
まずはじめに一つ想像してもらいたいこと
があるんです
アン地方で大きな地震が起きました大臣際
に起きましたん
でその大震災のをた地方じゃないところ
その別の授業で喫緊をツモってパーン
分かって
でそのかパーを被災地に届けで無料で配布
する
そういうボランティアあると思うんですね
タコマボランティアは果たして気せん
でしょうか
アンカーどう思いません
とか想像してみません
その想像した答えを想いからながら
こんな話がちょっと聞いてみてきます
僕のお父さんはパン屋さんです
ある日僕たちが暮らすまして街で大きな
地震が起きましたん
その通信なせいでお父さんのパン屋さん
建物が潰れてしまいましたん
でもお父さんは
みんな食べるものがないと困る館
そう言って例えばの中からターンはキザ
それから材料を引っ張り出してきて
よりも願いへパンを作りました
そして被災地では
ところいません
パン屋の営業を再開します
そこにボランティアがやって来ません
ボランティアんわ
お父さんのパン屋さんの横で
無料便パンを配りはします
お父さんの場合は今度はボランティア
見つけされました
という話があります
これ何が問題だったと思いますん
ボランティアをしてみましたら
まさか自分の行動が
和楽思えるなんて思わないわけですよ
だってへ
震災を持ってない地方でわざわざ義援金を
集めて
それをファンに変えて伊佐いじっていたん
です
社会的に見ても褒められるべきコールです
よねこの4 a
でも今回はそうそうな
残念ながら今活動は偽善と言われてしまっ
てもしょうがないんですよ
おいてボランティアおっしゃいません
そういうことは間違っていると思います
ボランティアとして悪いことだとしてして
ません
何が問題だったのか
あなたはどう思いません
私自身はこちらず指定とに視点が違えば
ニーズも違うということこれをしっかり
抑えられなかったっていうことが問題なん
じゃないかなというふうに思うんです
方が音があります
忙しそうに勉強して大学生
方や保険何も考えずに生きてく大学へ
ちょっといや準備グサッときたんですけど
まぁ ok と生活臭がいましたよ2願い
いたします
女こういう2人がある中で同じように遊び
に行こうよサポートしますよね
そしたら2人の反応は抑えが違うものが
いいと思います
忙し勉強している大学生は勉強中ながら
そういうこと言わないっていうのが反応
すると思いますし
ok できた大学生はこの行こうよって
いうなくてくれると思います
そうですよね
これ何が違うかって忙しくしているという
視点と暇そうにしてるっていう視点で
それぞれ
水が違ったわけですよ
忙しいとしている方はもっと勉強させて
ほしい
暇そうにしてる人は誘ってほしい
それぞれ別の支援なんですね別の先輩も
そぉ違う水が発生するんですよ
猫へ簡単な例に持ち帰るとすごくシンプル
で単純で当たり前のことだろう
言われるかもしれないんですけど
これは実際に行動郵送するとすごく難しい
んですよ
でさっきのパン屋の話ロンゲン脅すそう
伊佐市被災者の方々は食べるものがない
だろう
だからパーを無料で配るんだそれは3歳車
乗ってこっちまでたってもしていいから
新納八苦した感こそということが上がる
わけですよね
でも
パン屋さんあるという視点には
ボランティア戯れながら勝てなかったん
ですだからこそ
官役も隣でパワーにアップしそういう
ニーズに対しては無頓着だったわけですね
この指定ターンちょっと第1版だからこそ
まあ
ボランティアは偽善ラってしまったと
いうことなんですよ
私自身もボランティアをやりながら見た
ような経験をしたことがあります
高認っていう
すると皆さんご存知色
知的障がい者の方々がたくさん集まっ
でその赤松会社の方々の
まあ身の回り御社は若い子とパーする職員
さん少数
face シーズがあるんですよそういう
一緒に生活臭施設があるんですね
優しどちら実はもボランティアの方に行っ
た事があるんですけれども
そちらの施設で普段職人さんが手の回ら
ないボランティアをしてくれということで
私自身あのーそう
知的障害のある方の利用者さんっていいん
ですけども利用者の方々と
購入するティだからあんまりお話できない
から交流するっていうボランティアをて
しまったんですけれども
その中で
何かを触っていますと簡単にと器用家山の
若ママに一つ一つ連れて対応した方なん
ですね
まあこういうふうにたになり失礼組合して
bv 言ってくるので僕が気に入って
答えるとすごく嬉しそうな顔してくださる
んですよ
だから嬉しくなっちゃって中身関連こう
いうことは山を聞いたんですね
でそういう風にして1日が終わってもらっ
て帰るときにふっと一言先輩に言われたん
です
あるかと思う
どういうことかというとこれも私自身
利用者さん
その知的障害のある方もニールしか見えて
なかったからこそそういうボランティアを
してしまったんです何が言いたいかという
と
楊さんは普段は袴もするっていうことを
ずっと抑えて生きてきたんです
まあそれがいいことかどうかは別として
とりあえず押さえて生きていく入っていく
中で日常治ってきたと
それをある日非日常である私が
ボランティアと銘打って踏み込んでいって
そのわがままのをしたいという気持ちを
爆発させてしまう
だからこそ
イオンさんは次からもしかした職人さんに
生来に飯もするかもしれないと
そういう形で本来あるべき日常を今して
しまったん
まあ要するに方にもそういう音なかったん
ですね
それは職員さんに一度を壊さないで欲しい
みーそ私が完全に無視して
利用者さんの好みを聞いて欲しいてニーズ
だけに応えてしまったからこそ起きたこと
なんです
これは残念ながら
偽善のボランティアだったかなって初めて
私自身の気づい一瞬かん
まあこういうふうにボランティアをする中
でももちろん保留以前ということがあるん
ですけれどもこれは日常生活の機械でも
同じだと思うんです
日常生活でも相手のニーズに対して
まあそれをかなえるような行動をする
で他の人を傷付けないような行動するって
いうのは大なり小なり
毎日皆さんが経験していることだと思うん
ですよね
でそういう行動をするうえ
してわからなかっ
じゃあどうぞ
宴に回転することができる
いやましたんですよすごく単純な話
多角的な視点を持っているなんです
これ何か大きな事件に巻き込まれたときに
はその事件に直面したときに自分の視点
からだ
何も盗られないから別の姿勢から見てい
ましょうねっていう話とは少しニュアンス
が違うんつ
ね駄目ことかっていうと
こちらですねこちらが目が自分をタップし
ています
ねえ
この死生観
物事をドライブ
いう時に自分の姿勢の中の民主のこの赤い
言うんですよこ
自分のして家の中に入ってるに入るしか
見えないわけですよ
そうすると行動する購入っさんもその水に
応えられる部分でした
行動できないわけですよ
つまりこの横にある4つの黄色い矢印っ子
れイメージなんですけど他の人のニーズに
関してはまったく無頓着でそういう行動を
してしまう
ということなんですん
だからそう
自分の持っている辞典っていうものを
どんどん広げていけないいかんっていけ
ないんじゃないかと
そういうふうに気付いたわけですねつまり
自分の持っているしてんっていいものを
広げられるよう毎日31どんなところに
アンテナを持って視点を増やし例えば
まあ切られていった
fire さんの支援
たとえばさっきの例データー
職員さんの支援
それ用の一個一個意識してしっかり
張り巡らして自分の視点っていうのも
どんどん広げていけば
選べ
に受け止められるニーズというものは
どんどん広くなっているとっ
そういう風に思うわけですよね
でそうすればそれに対して行動を起こせ
行動っていう質問レベルをどんどん上がっ
ていくんじゃないかと
ぜひ気づきましたこれが私自身
ボランティアを通してすごく
自分の中で小行きてーなー職員が気づき
だったのでぜひ皆さん
シェアでいければなというふうに思いまし
てこちらもに来たしていただきました
まあ簡単にもう一度振り返るで言うと最初
は2000というテーマからお話をさせて
いただきました
まあ
パイパン配るボランティアをした人はこの
パン屋さんという視点が欠けていたから
こそ
偽善と呼ばれるボランティアをしてしまっ
たと思う
だからこそ
して増やしていかなければならないんです
これはふらーん普通に生活していると
淡い過去を見過ごしてしまうようなそう
いう視点すらもしっかり意識して受け止め
て自分の支援に変えていこうという話なん
洗剤ができれば自分の成し得ることだし
よる行動っていうのはどんどん精度が
上がっていって
大きないい part 5せる社会に入っ
てないインパクト思うんでそういうことが
できるようになるんじゃないかと思いまし
たこのまでシェアさせていただきました
だけでもしてへん共感してくださる方が
いらっしゃったら一緒に甲子園を増やして
いいことを頑張ってディスターブ形で
過ごすません
これからどんどん広げていけばいいじゃ
ないかなという思います
だけで少し短いんですけれどもこれで
終わりたいと思いますご清聴どうも
ありがとうございました